vous avez un top 5 des plus grosses
rigolades dans des émissions d' aventure
alors il ya top ce qu'ont rappelé de
lydia est là participe à la présenter la
précédente édition de pékin express
il est arrivé une énorme tas nas lors
d'une épreuve elle avait été attaquée
par une vachette regarder
[Musique]
elle m'a tuer me tuer ça m'a vu glisse à
bord du bus qui revient lui samedi vie
est là pour battle la shooter au j'ai
vraiment peigne pour lydia la peau
rester belgique et au numéro 4 est ce
que vous vous rappelez en terrain connu
ces faits pourraient plus faire déjà
fait ses preuves en terre inconnue est
ce que vous vous rappelez d'un lama qui
avait craché sur quelqu'un oui sur qui a
sur qui est ce que vous le savez chez
vous yadin lama en terre inconnue un
lama crash muriel robin non shy'm vous
dit muriel robin sait mais l'a pas fait
en terre inconnue elle a fait mike horn
alors regardez regardez ça c'est au
numéro 4
[Musique]
ces principes
tu t'es fait un petit qui perd alors pas
du tout dans ça va mieux ça mais non non
non arrêté est joué vous parlez de la
carte aux trésors sur france 3 jusqu'en
fin un top 5 pour 10 émission d'aventuré
nous on en reste trois ans regarder ça
c'est un truc qui nous a fait graver
rigoler c'est une candidate qui
demandait un automobiliste si elle peut
monter dans sa voiture et elle se prend
le plus gros vent de l'histoire du 21e
siècle regarder de musique
le mot sur un vélo connaît ce que vous
pouvez suivre
[Applaudissements]
ça c'était belgique ça gros gros vent
les chéris bien sûr en numéro 2 1 au
numéro 2 c'était notre moundir moundir
dans koh lanta même s'il n'a jamais
gagné l'émission c'est le candidat le
plus cultes de l'émission une guerre
j'espère qu'il va bien mon chéri mon
frérot ses nombreux coups de gueule ont
fait la légende c'est en 2009 sans
numéro 2 ça des trucs davanture garde
aucun donneur au puy et en numéro 1 les
chéris c'est bien sûr dans fort boyard
pour nous la scène la plus dark a de
toutes les émissions de la voiture c'est
la gifle de la faute les expliquer ça
j'ai bien sûr et new beat feuz dit comme
ça alors nous le dit regarder et à
brioude explique regarde et elle a bien
permis de souvent bien plus on sait ça
c'est yvette usa ont fait savoir de quel
méchant à gauche alors qu'il est méchant
c'était valu à là on a rajouté le bruit
du bas-lac il est méchant de ce qu'il
avait énervé avant pas quoi et on vous
le dira hors classement
on a mis un truc au reclassement cgg de
koh lanta
quand ils essayent de nager et regardez
bien son slip ça en cette période
moi je me la passe en moi je suis en
chine mon petit bas de regarder ça y est
gégé a touché la boue et les ils
paniquent et ils n'arrivent plus du tout
avancé chez j'ai fait du surplace
il ne parvient pas à rejoindre le ponton
à la nage gégé a fait de son mieux
il s'est rapproché du ponton mais il est
toujours en difficulté dans l'eau
[Musique]
voilà si vous voulez l'écrire vous
pouvez pas